[Musique]
qu'est ce que l'amérique représente pour
vous
[Musique]
votre expulsion est sans appel vous
pouvez rien faire pour nous aider je
suis désolé mais c'est chez moi ici
new york c'est chez moi il y à 13,8
milliards d'années le big bang donna
naissance aux étoiles aux planètes aux
galaxies à l'échelle de l'âge de
l'univers
c'est comme si nos vies commencé et fini
c'est le même jour je m'appelle daniel
moi c'est natacha ya quoi dans ce carnet
cv poème que j'ai écrit des poèmes des
poèmes sur quoi non attends je sais sur
l'amour entre autres et ben moi l'amour
j'y prends pas alors pas de magie pas de
destin pas de ils sont faits l'un pour
l'autre
je suis sûr que tu tournes très
amoureuse de moi si je voulais il
suffirait d'une journée je te donne une
heure c'est quoi la recette qui fait que
tu tombe amoureuse toi pour moi ces
amitiés plus alchimie plus l'ingrédient
secret tu sais quoi l'ingrédient secret
on l'a toi et moi tu crois que je vais
changer d'avis tu rêves tes pattes
taille même avec ta cravate patent du
prat pathak j'ai dit pas de taille en
plus ma famille vient pas que tu as eue
en 3d coréen n'a rien à voir avec ce que
j'ai dit alors je te préviens t'attends
pas des excuses
or mais c'est parce que je te demande
pas je m'attends à beaucoup mieux que
des excuses
[Musique]
afin de croître si peur si tu veux tout
savoir je suis pas né ici ma famille
quitte le bild il nous arrive à vrai
truc je sais que tu ressens la même
chose
les choix qu'on fait
[Musique]
le chemin qu'on décide d'emprunter
on n'a pas l'éternité
[Musique]
tout ce qu'on a c'est une journée